okay ellie it's cake week on the show
and
one of the stories that was my very
favorite that you and sam pasternack one
of our producers spoke about
um was your mom's traditional cake will
you tell us about it
okay first of all i couldn't be happier
that i'm here during cake
week the most iconic of weeks my mom
is the best mom on the planet and every
year
for ever since i could eat solids so
maybe for 38 years
she has been making me a chocolate cake
with mocha icing for my birthday
there is a picture of this cake it
has such a special place in my heart um
when she would make it when i was you
know in elementary school middle school
i was allowed to have cake for
breakfast the following days after my
birthday until the cake was gone
when i was in college my mom made this
cake packaged it up and
shipped it to me and somehow it arrived
intact
which is no small feat it's a testament
to how great the cake is
how strong her love is but it is just
the most magical cake and i got to have
it this spring
i was in st louis from the whole the
lockdown
and i got to have it this spring and it
was again one of those we talked about
bright spots during this pandemic and
that was a bright spot
i have to say that that just gave me
such goals when i read that
as a mom and hearing you say that she's
the best mom i mean
ever since i had my daughters it's like
nothing matters in my life
and you know we're all gonna you know
have some
humor and dysfunction and things in our
families there's no such thing as like
a perfect road it's perfectly imperfect
um
but you've just i think that's such a
beautiful story and i think it's really
inspiring and motivating for
all us moms out there and you're a mom
and you have two beautiful children
to step up and create those traditions
and memories like your mom
absolutely by the way you got me with
that tweet about surviving the pandemic
my gosh
it's true these kids are doing amazing
jobs just incredible jobs
oh i'm so glad because you know we were
all work together here but sometimes
we're in a bit of a vacuum and
i just was i sometimes come in and i'm
like that's what's so fun about doing
this show day to day is you get to come
in with
what you're really experiencing and in
2020 we got to keep it
real and in the moment because it's
shifting so quickly
so thank you for that feedback because
um
okay we're gonna do a live
reading from christmas magic a play you
wrote for your mother
yes i cannot believe you are now
starring in this play we wrote this play
um you know when i was 10 or 12 put it
on in the front hall this is a play
called
christmas magic again it's one of these
um homemade
uh uh productions and christmas magic is
a
story about the true meaning of
christmas and so very quickly
um annie bellamy is the star of our of
the
heroine i should say of our play and um
she's made her mom and her sister some
homemade cards for
uh christmas cause she doesn't have a
lot of money to spend while her
classmate laughs at her
says you dope of the true meaning of
christmas is presents
got to get them something flashy
something expensive otherwise there's no
point to christmas
so annie rips up her cards she gets
a hot pink hairdryer for her sister and
a nail dryer for her mom
and then lo and behold on christmas
morning underneath the tree
there's no hair dryer there's no nail
dryer the cards
are intact they are under the tree they
are not ripped up
it's nothing short of a miracle and um
i think that's where uh that's the setup
to the scene that
you and i are about to perform okay well
i'm very excited and
ready you did that you did that very
quickly okay
i saw an opportunity okay there is the
live theater going on youtube stop sit
sit
sit you're our audience sit yep
big guys oh they're too cute okay
i'm annie you're annie if you don't mind
what but i don't i can't
annie what beautiful cards these are
how good you are at drawing christmas
trees and candy cane
but no i i love the sequins
i'm telling you this doesn't make any
sense
what doesn't make sense i think it makes
sense
you're great at art and mr bunton your
art teacher agrees
remember your report card no but you
don't understand i ripped these cards
up what
why because i realized that my gifts
were too babyish and
i knew i had to get you something
fancier so i ripped up my cards and i
got you a hairdryer and terry i got you
a nail dryer mom would you do
such a thing annie i did it because
katie told me the true meaning of
christmas
what did katie say
she let me know that christmas is all
about the presents and that
we are too old to be making cards
anymore
honey i have to tell you something katie
is wrong
sure it's nice to show people that you
like them by giving them something
they'll enjoy
but i enjoy this card more than any nail
dryer
or hair dryer really mom
annie you gave us the greatest gift of
all
love
[Music]
[Applause]
i can't believe i got to start in an
ellie kemper original
i was so excited i made sure to ask sam
what my motivation was
and as a director and the creator and
writer of this play
sincerity was important so
thank you ellie it is a privilege to be
in your world
i love you and your mom and i can't
think of not only
the apropos-ness of cake week but the
holidays in general
to hear that story about you guys it's
goals
all the way and so
thank you and i love what you said about
comedy and there's just nothing more
than i feel like this show's intention
is is to celebrate
the art of comedy because i don't think
i would know how to get through life
without it
but i need the heart too and you are
the heart and the humor my potent
favorite combo
that means so much to me and again i
just want to emphasize how much joy you
bring people on a daily basis so thank
you for that right back at you
thank you so much our wild wacky film
the standout is out tomorrow on vod and
digital
and we will just continue to celebrate
you
with everything that you do i can't wait
and let's do this again thank you ellie
kemper
thank you for having me
[Music]
you